انضم الينا الان من بيروت الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه العميد الياسحنا اهلا وسهلا
بك بوتين يقول الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
بدا
هل من مؤشرات تؤكد فعلا ذلك
محمد هناك خطابين اساسيين على الساحه يعني
هناك خطاب رسمي الاعلى فيه هو مقاله
الرئيس بوتين يليهي وزير الدفاع على ان
الهجوم بدا وهناك انجازات عسكريه وصمت
كامل وشامل من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه وحتى
الحكومه الاوكرانيه الهجوم الذي ينتظره
الكل سوف لن يكون ذلك الهجوم الكبير
والسريع ويعني بكل القوى التي حضرتها
اوكرانيا هذه المرحله هي مرحله الاستطلاع
يعني كما يقال
جراوند يعني هي مرحله تحضير الارضيه عبر
على سبيل المثال كما اتى في التقرير ضرب
الداخل خلق بلبله في الداخل الروسي ضرب
العمق ضرب كل ما له علاقه باللوجستيه
الروسيه وبالتالي المرحله الثانيه هي
مرحله جص النبض على جبهه بطول 9 كيلو متر
لمعرفه امكنه
نقاط الضعف وبالتالي التراكمات من
النجاحات اليوم دائما في اول مرحله من
الحرب من يهاجم هو الذي يتكبت الخسائر
الاكبر خاصه ان روسيا كان لديها الوقت
لتحضير بنيه دفاعيه كامله وشامله على طول
الجبهه ككل الان وقت حلت اشهر الصيف ما
المتوقع في سير المعارك
هناك ازمه المصداقيه لدى اوكرانيا لديها
كل شيء عليها ان تحقق شيء معين الانجاز
ياتينا بواقع امني واستراتيجي على الصعيد
الاوكراني والاوروبي والفشل قد ياتي بشيء
مهم جدا يعني يؤدي الى نسف كل المنظومه
الامنيه يجب ان يكون هناك نصر اوكراني
كافي لتبرير هذا التجهيز وهذه الاهتمام
الغربي من النيتو من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وبالتالي الزام الحكومه الروسيه
نتحدث عن رئيس بوتين الزامها الى وقف وقف
نار الذهاب الى طاوله المفاوضات هذا الامر
يجب ان يكون كبير جدا وهذا لن يحصل الا
اذا حصل في منطقه
بول وبالتالي ضرب الجسر البري الذي يعتبر
العمود الفقري لك ل مشروع الرئيس بوتين
عندما ضم الاقاليم الاربعه
يعني مثلما تابعنا قبل قليل الخارطه لو
اردنا ان نقول باختصار الان الميزان
العسكري كيف يبدو ماذا نقول
ليس هناك من ميزان عسكري بالمطلق الميزان
العسكري هو لصالح روسيه يبدو اليوم من
ينتصر هو في الكيف في ايه طريقه وفي موضوع
المفاجاه محمد المفاجاه غائبه عن المسرح
الاوكراني المفاجاه الاستراتيجيه الكل
يعرف اين الهجوم الكل يعرف ماذا حضر ولكن
اليوم الحديث عن المفاجات التكتيكيه عن
نقاط الضعف في عده اماكن اذا تراكمت مع
بعضها قد تؤدي الى
مكسب استراتيجي شكرا جزيلا لك العميل من
بيروت